[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
massive wildfires unprecedented in their
scope continue to sweep across huge
portions of the west tonight
in oregon half a million residents have
been forced to evacuate their homes
that's one of every 10 people in the
entire state
dozens are dead including small children
but the fires still are not close to
contained
watch this report from fox's jeff paul
months of tinder dry conditions
added to days of high winds and hot
temperatures creating
a perfect firestorm across the west
california is one of the hardest hit
with a record-breaking 3 million acres
burned
and nearly 4 000 homes and buildings
lost so far
a 12-year-old boy and his grandmother
are among the latest deaths
the flames are spreading so fast it
really doesn't give people much time to
get out the fire is also taking a toll
in washington state where more than 100
homes are gone
and a one-year-old boy died as his
family tried to flee the flames
and in oregon more than 35 fires are
burning
with at least five small towns destroyed
resources across the west
are stretched thin it is awful and it
continues as we speak right now
walls of flame consuming everything in
their path homes
thousands and thousands untold numbers
of animals
and of course as we said human beings
too it is tragedy on a massive scale
when something this terrible happens
decent people
pause they put their own interests aside
for a moment they consider
how they can help we've seen that kind
of selflessness before in this country
this is
remember the anniversary of 9 11. but
there are others
for whom altruism is an unknown concept
self-interest is all they know
these people do not pause they never do
they relentlessly press forward for any
advantage
under any circumstances they see human
suffering as a means to increase their
personal power
these are the people who turn funerals
into political rallies
and feel no shame for doing it as
americans
burned to death people like this swung
into action immediately
they went on television with a partisan
talking point
climate change they said caused these
fires
they didn't explain how exactly that
happened how did climate change do that
they didn't tell us but they just kept
saying it
in the hands of democratic politicians
climate change is like systemic racism
in the sky
you can't see it but rest assured it's
everywhere
and it's deadly and like systemic racism
it is your fault
the american middle class did it they
caused climate change
they ate too many hamburgers they drove
too many suvs they had too many children
a lot of them wear t-shirts to work and
didn't finish college and that causes
climate change too and worst of all some
of them
may vote for donald trump in november
and if there's anything that
absolutely definitively causes climate
change and literally over a hundred
percent of scientists agree with this
established fact
it is voting for donald trump you might
as well start a tire fire in your yard
joe biden has checked the science and he
agrees with this
yesterday the people in biden's staff
who understand the internet tweeted out
an image of the wildfires along with
this message
quote climate change is already here and
we're witnessing its devastating effects
every single day
we have to get president trump out of
the white house end quote
so once again by voting for donald trump
you are causing climate change which
causes devastating fires
you by your vote have made hundreds of
thousands of oregonians homeless tonight
you've murdered people joe biden's
closest friend in the world
a prominent kite surfer on martha's
vineyard called barack obama
echoed that message with his trademark
restraint
obama declared that your life depends on
voting for joe biden
hold on a minute you might ask doesn't
this very
same barack obama own a 12 million
dollar spread
right on the ocean in massachusetts at a
time when sea levels are rising
so fast we're about to see killer whales
in the rockies
well that doesn't make sense it doesn't
seem like barack obama could be very
concerned about
climate change and by the way didn't
obama go to law school
when did he become a scientist those
seem like reasonable questions
on the other hand lawyers pretending to
be scientists
are now everywhere in the democratic
party here for example is the governor
of washington state jay inslee
inslee is a proud graduate of willamette
university law school
he's explaining he's already figured out
the cause of the fires
watch and these are conditions that are
exacerbated by the changing climate that
we are suffering
and i do not believe that we should
surrender
these subdivisions or these houses
to climate change exacerbated fires we
should fight the cause of these fires
so i mismanaged my state now it's on
fire
you're required to give me more power
right
you see how that works but as a factual
matter
this is a croc there is not a single
scientist
on earth who knows whether or by how
much these fires may have been quote
exacerbated by warmer temperatures
caused by climate change
all we have is conjecture from a handful
of scientists and many politicians
none of whom has reached a definitive
conclusion daniel swain for example he's
a climate scientist at ucla
conceded recently that it's quote hard
to determine whether climate change
played a role in sparking the fires
okay that's what science is it's gradual
it's incremental often it's tentative we
don't say things we don't know for
certain
it's the opposite of politics they have
nothing in common meanwhile back in the
material world
investigators have determined that the
massive eldorado fire in california
which has torched nearly 14 000 acres
was caused by people setting off some
kind of fireworks
and then on wednesday police announced
that a criminal investigation is
underway into the massive alameda fire
in ashland oregon the southern part of
the state
the sheriff there said it's too early to
say what caused the fire
but he did say human remains were found
at the suspected
origin of it so nothing is being ruled
out tonight including arson
as always with these things the more you
know the more facts the more details
you know the more complicated it becomes
so serious people and there are still
some
are just beginning to gather evidence to
figure out how this started
and thinking through how to prevent it
going forward but at the same time
unfortunately
our media are giving voice to deeply
unserious people
partisan people and they're on
television drowning out nuance don't
worry about the facts they say just
trust
us the sky is orange over san francisco
because households making 40 grand a
year made the mistake of voting
republican
therefore you must give us total control
of the nation's economy
the green new deal it's mandatory now
watch amateur arson detective nancy
pelosi explain
mother earth is angry she's telling us
whether she's telling us with hurricanes
on the gulf coast fires in the west
whatever it is that the climate crisis
is real and has an impact
mother nature is angry please when was
the last time nancy pelosi went
outside could she identify a single tree
no an astra of course
all we know is what she said climate
change caused this
of course it did because no matter what
the natural disaster is
hurricanes tornadoes acne whatever
climate change did it in other words you
did it and
to repent for doing it you need to give
us full control of your life
now keep in mind the person telling you
this nancy pelosi owns at least
two sub sub zero freezers she showed
them to us on television each one costs
ten thousand dollars they use a lot of
energy
and like barack obama like joe biden
nancy pelosi constantly flies around the
country
privately between her multi-million
dollar estate so if she cared about
climate change of course she wouldn't be
doing that
she doesn't and now they do her
supporters otherwise they'd be masked
outside of her
estates in anger they wouldn't be trying
to
destroy the hair salon that exposed her
hypocrisy
but it's not about science it's
certainly not about the earth again
these are people who don't go outside
who know nothing about nature
it's about blaming and ritually
humiliating
the american middle class for daring to
elect someone they don't like
joe biden knows that the pennsylvanians
who'd be financially ruined by the
fracking ban he supports
are the same pennsylvanians who flipped
pennsylvania red in 2016 for the first
time in a generation
think they're holding a grudge you bet
they are one of the reasons joe biden
doesn't go outside because his handlers
won't allow him
is because when he does he has a
tendency to show
pure undisguised contempt for the middle
class he supposedly cares so deeply
about
in 2019 you'll remember he openly mocked
coal miners he suggested they just get
programming jobs once they're all fired
watch i come from a family where
an area where it's coal mining scranton
anybody could go down 300 to three
thousand feet in the mine
sharon hill can learn how to program as
well
learn to code hilarious joe biden should
learn to code
keep us posted on how that goes but
there isn't time for that
the world is ending there's no time to
pause and savor the deep layers of
hypocrisy here stop
we're too busy we're measuring our lives
in minutes now last summer sandy cortez
did the math on all of this she's good
at math
and she calculated we only have 12 years
left to live
the world is going to end in 12 years if
we don't address climate change
like this is the war this is our world
war ii
man that sounds bad and we're starting
to wreck your night on a friday but
actually it's worse than that
much worse than that consider this just
four months after she gave us that
warning sandy cortez tweeted that we
only have
10 years to cut carbon emissions in half
so think about that we lost two years in
just four months
at that rate we could literally all be
dead unless joe biden wins in november
which is of course
what they're saying underneath it all on
tuesday california governor gavin newsom
pretty much
said it out loud newsom has abandoned
science completely he did it long ago
science is too stringent for gavin
newsom too western too patriarchal
newsom is now a man of faith he's
decided that climate change caused
all of this and that's final he's not
listening to any other arguments
watch i have no patience and i say this
lovingly not as an ideologue but as
someone who prides himself on being
opened argument interested in evidence
but i quite literally have no patience
for climate change deniers it simply
follows uh completely inconsistent
that point of view with the reality on
the ground
i'm not an audio log but anyone who
disagrees with me
must be ignored and eliminated i don't
want to hear
any countervailing facts or evidence
none but i'm not an audiologist
so people like gavin newsom has
announced they don't want to listen to
climate change deniers which raises the
central question what is a climate
change denier
well climate change denier is anyone who
thinks a ruling class
has done a very poor job running their
states running their country protecting
the people they were hired to protect
and watch over
so are we climate change deniers if we
point out that the state of california
has failed to implement meaningful
deforestation measures
that might have dramatically explode the
spread of these wildfires
does that make us deniers because in
2018 a state oversight agency in
california
found that years of poor or non-existent
forest management policies in the sierra
nevada forests
had contributed to the fires one of the
few republicans who still holds elected
office in that state state assemblyman
heath flora last year called on using
the state's 22 billion dollar budget
surplus
probably the last one in its history to
implement vegetation management because
fires don't obviously spread
as well if they're not connected by huge
forests which function as kindling
all of that is obvious which means you
can't say it out loud
the natural world facts nature itself is
anathema to ideologues like this
the same people telling you they're
protecting nature hate nature everything
about nature
presumably also a climate change denier
if you point out that six
of the oregon national guard's wildfire
fighting helicopters
aren't in oregon anymore where are they
you might wonder
they're in afghanistan so instead of
dropping water to suppress the blazes
the chinook helicopters are busy
supplying a war effort that's been going
on for nearly 20 years
for no reason so how'd that happen
and what's the effect of it those might
be good questions to ask of
i don't know gavin newsom jay inslee
governor of oregon
does anyone even care and the answer of
course is no nobody cares about the
details
at all they don't care about the lives
of the people they govern they don't
care about facts they don't care about
science
it was just last week that the mayor of
los angeles eric garcetti admitted
on the record that la has become
completely third world
which it has unfortunately of course
garcetti didn't blame himself
for the degradation of one of the great
american cities that he runs
no he blamed you you did it quote
it's almost 3 p.m garcetti tweeted time
to turn off
major appliances set the thermostat to
78 degrees or use a fan instead turn off
excess lights
and unplug any appliances you're not
using we need every californian
to help conserve energy please do your
part
oh you got to wonder if you were able to
go to garcetti's house which you're not
can't get past the bodyguards you pay
for but if you were is he following
these recommendations no but it's not
about him
it's about the people he's supposed to
be helping the ones he's now blaming
he wants them to suffer to fix a problem
that he and his fellow democrats in
california
created even now as residents are facing
sweeping power outages
in addition to the wildfires in the
meantime gavin newsom has vowed that
fifty percent of the
energy in california fifty percent of
their grid will be based on quote
renewable sources within a decade that
means sources like wind and solar power
the truth is you can't dial up wind or
solar in moments of extreme demand
moments like right now during the heat
wave sweeping california
gavin newsom was asked last month
whether he would consider revising his
stance
given that the blackouts have left
millions of californians without power
and presumably killed people
because that's what happens you don't
have electricity and newsom responded
this way quote
we are going to radically change the way
we produce and consume
energy in other words no
we're not changing in other words the
blackouts will continue until morale
improves